welcome back it's my surprise birthday  party and my presents have been great  food great drinks and amazing friends  and that's all about anyone needs in  life that's what i'm saying  happy birthday  to you  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  happy birthday  to you  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  happy birthday this is a wonderful cake  from big sugar bake shop  and they are apparently your favorite so  here you go this is your cake those are  the cakes we get everything absolute  honor to be able to bring this to you  today to surprise you here on your  birthday show you are the sweetest and  the realest  person i'm the best host  on daytime  thank you so much  thank you thank you happy birthday  [Applause]  oh  [Music]  you